when's the last time you had a workout
don't remember how many days a week are
you hitting gym none so who here doesn't
work out at least 30 minutes a day look
guys I had fried chicken at 11 p.m. last
night I'm clearly not trying to be
healthier I'm Aaron Hines I am a
personal trainer the goal today is where
do you feel you can take your fitness
and your nutrition game to the top level
I am 37 years old I'm 5 9 and weigh
about 190 295 pounds for the American
male that's about average the average
BMI is 29 which is overweight what's
holding you back I can't find the time
talk to me a little bit about what your
day looks like my job is to be sat down
in front of the computer how many of you
guys are generally sitting for 10 hours
or more per day just sitting stagnant
for 30 minutes is gonna decrease your
metabolism by about 90% what the body
needs is constant change sitting for so
long your body's actually going to start
to hold on to your fat how many of us
get outside and do something at least
recreational once or twice per day none
of us can you find time maybe every hour
and a half to take five minutes to do
something yeah absolutely some of us
have like standing desks well you don't
want to be standing for too long at a
standing desks it's gonna be very
important to just do a little bit of
dynamic stretching a lot of that blood
it can rush down causing localized ankle
edema aka cankles don't want us we don't
want those we've been saying you for
half hour right now we have so everybody
get up let's get some squats go Internet
it's not necessarily the time that you
put in I mean you need at least 30
minutes but it's what you do while
you're in there even hit those squats in
the bathroom if I do it over as a bowl
I'm even more efficient whatever it
takes if I'm like more than slightly
winded from that how big of a problem
diet and exercise are together so this
is it huh these are snacks diet is gonna
be about 70% this is a lot of processed
food a lot of saturated fat I don't like
anything that I see raise your hand if
you've had some sort of fast food within
the past week yes are those your chips
maybe as far as I did I did eat fast
food miss me you see unlike the dietary
facts I don't know what to look for rule
number one if it has a label try to
limit it or stay away from it was
anybody had any kind of candy whatsoever
within the past week soda included I
don't care if it's diet oh yeah
see this these are the things we got to
eliminate where do I get food that isn't
bad that's still quick it's all about
the preparation so start to think ahead
bacon bacon and more bacon so we have
any vegetables in here no nothing these
expired a month ago so yeah you still
haven't eaten today have you no train
the body to be able to eat a number of
different meals throughout the day as we
speak the muscle that you have on your
body is being broken down and used for
energy I've heard that dairy isn't that
good for you overeat spread yeah how
much meat can we eat too much of
anything is gonna be a bad thing do not
eliminate the fats and the carbs that
you're putting into your body just make
sure that they're the right kind who
here has had any alcohol say within the
past week raise your hand if you know
any other culture dance don't drink your
calories to drinks at least a gallon of
water per day when we look at everything
you have your diet you have your
exercise you have your sleep talk to me
a little bit about the nights you have a
hard time falling asleep I said most
often so my mind that's racing all of
these tie in together so if one is
dropping it's gonna bring down
everything else how many of us get less
than eight hours of sleep per night on
okay I love sleep yeah this is
replenishing your body you don't have a
TV in your bedroom which is great I do
have an iPad over there so let me see
it's show of hands if you are watching
TV or on the internet for more than five
hours a day save the bed for just
sleeping okay and getting in the bed
about 30 minutes earlier as soon as I
get up from my computer I pull out my
feet I think about you've had not the
greatest night's sleep you're right back
in your bed you're doing your emails
you're depriving your body of nutrients
you're setting yourself up for failure
and I think I had a philosophy of like
well when you're young it's not as
important to be healthy for a guy how
much more dangerous is it get to not be
healthy as you age once you get out of
your teen years it's extremely dangerous
for us not to be healthy because guys
moreso than women are more susceptible
to things like hypertension high
cholesterol and those things don't go
away this is step one we're just
realizing what the possibilities could
be based on for this talk who here is
going to be able to implement at least
some kind of small change into their
everyday life in terms of fitness and/or
diet show hands perfect